Now that you've seen how to make changes
public by sharing them on GitHub,
I wanted to show you a work flow you can
use to get feedback on your changes to
a project before you
update the master branch.
As an example, here is the recipes
repository both locally on my own
computer and my fork on GitHub.
If I have a change I
want Sarah's feedback on,
then first I'll make that change
locally on a separate branch.
Next, I'll push that change to my fork.
Now my change is shared on GitHub, so
Sarah can see it, but
it's not in the master branch.
That way if Sarah finds a problem
with my change when she reviews it,
I won't have broken master.
Next, I'll use a feature of GitHub
called pull requests that make it
easy for Sarah to see exactly what
I've changed and leave comments.
When we're both ready, I'll merge
this change into the master branch.
Right now, I want to change the cake
recipe to use canola oil instead of
vegetable oil, since it's healthier.
First, I'll make a new
branch called different-oil.
Then I'll check out that branch, and
I'll go ahead and make the change.
Now, I want to show Sarah
the changes I've made, so
I'll add them, commit them,
and push them.
Note that this time I'm running
git push origin different-oil to
push the different-oil
branch instead of master.
Now that I've pushed my branch,
it's possible to see it on GitHub.
To see what branches exist,
I can choose this drop down, and
I can see that right now I'm
looking at the master branch.
And here's the different-oil
branch that I just pushed.
This list of branches is the same list
I would see if I ran get branch on
the repository on GitHub.
So only branches that I've
pushed to GitHub will show up.
To see what the files look like on the
different-oil branch, I can click on it,
which analogous to running git checkout.
Sarah could also do this and
then view the commit history
to see what changes I've made.
Instead though I'm going to create
a pull request for my changes.
I'll go back to the main page for
the repository, and I could click
the compare and pull request button here
since I just pushed the branch recently.
But if I'd pushed it less recently and
that button wasn't there, then I
would check out this branch, scroll
down a little and click Pull Request.
By default, GitHub assumes I
want to merge my changes into
the original repository,
which is Larry's repository.
But instead, I want to merge my changes
into the master branch of my own fork.
So I'll scroll to right and click Edit.
And now I can change the base
fork to cbuckey-uda/recipes.
Now I'll scroll down and to the right,
and click Create pull request.
Now, GitHub makes a view that shows
all of the commits that are present in
this pull request and
all of the changes that have been made.
If I go back up to the repository and
scroll to the right, I can also
see a list of all Pull Requests.
So, Sarah can check this list and
see that I'd like to merge
these changes into master.
Now, I'll turn you over to Sarah
while she looks at my pull request.
>> Since I'm watching Caroline's
fork of the recipes repository,
I got an email notifying me
when she made a pull request.
I can click through in this email
to see the pull request on GitHub.
You might be wondering why
these are called pull requests.
Caroline initiated this request, but
she's not asking to pull anything.
She's trying to merge one of
her changes into master, or
you might think of this as her
trying to push into master.
So why is it called a pull request?
It's because she's requesting that I
pull her branch into the master branch.
Another good name for
this might be a merge request.
But, pull request is what GitHub picked,
so we'll go with that.
So Caroline wants me to merge
her different-oil branch into
the master branch.
Since the master branch
is the main branch, and
it's what people will see when
they first come to the repository,
I want to make sure that it really looks
good before actually doing the merge.
All right.
It looks like she just changed
vegetable to, oh, canols?
I think she meant canola,
based on the name of the pull request.
I don't really want to merge this
in because it has a spelling error.
That would probably be confusing if
anybody was looking at this later.
So instead of merging it now,
I'm actually going to leave a comment.
I could put my comment here,
commenting on the whole change, or
I could do an inline comment here.
I think I'll choose that option.
At this point,
I'll go back to the main pull request.
If there were more commits,
I could look at them here, but
since there's only one,
I don't need to look at anything else.
If I had decided that the change
was good, and ready to be pulled in
right now, I could have pressed
this Merge pull request button.
This will only appear when the merge
could go through without a conflict.
So it's a nice indicator to the person
reviewing the changes, as to whether or
not it's really ready to go.
If the change would have created a merge
conflict, I would ask Caroline to merge
master into her branch first, so that I
could see how she resolves the conflict.
That way I know that when her code
finally does get added to master,
there's no chance that something's
going to go wrong with a bad merge.
All right,
at this point you should go ahead and
make the change that Caroline described
by creating a new branch off of master,
and committing a change that switches
vegetable oil out in favor of canola.
You can make a typo or
other mistake on purpose so
that you'll have a reason to
update the pull request later.
You don't have to.
Go ahead and push your new branch
to the fork, and then use GitHub to
initiate a pull request, but make sure
not to click the Merge button yet